Otherwise known as Agent 13, Sharon Carter is
one of S.H.I.E.L.D.'s deadliest operatives.
But what's the full story behind this legendary
ally of Captain America? From her family roots
to her most dangerous missions, this
is the untold truth of Sharon Carter.
One thing worth knowing is that Sharon
Carter wasn't actually the first Agent 13:
Her aunt Margaret "Peggy" Carter holds that
distinction. During her time as Agent 13,
Peggy fights in the French resistance,
falls in love with Captain America, and
takes on the first iteration of HYDRA.
Naturally, Peggy is heartbroken when Cap
disappears. However, she quickly overcomes
her grief, joins a number of different spy
agencies, and eventually becomes an agent ofS.H.I.E.L.D.
Her older brother Harrison
later welcomes a daughter named Sharon,
and the two become very close - in fact, Sharon
sees Peggy as something of a personal hero.
Having grown up dazzled by tales
of her aunt's wartime exploits,
Sharon decides to join S.H.I.E.L.D. -
and even adopts her aunt's old codename.
But then Peggy suddenly relapses into grief
for Cap and is placed into an asylum. She
becomes so delusional, in fact, that she
imagines Sharon to be her kid sister,
and Harrison to be her father. This
strange plot line was introduced
mostly because of the increasing time lag
between World War II and the modern era.
In the end, it turns out that Peggy is
being manipulated by Doctor Faustus,
but Cap rescues her and she snaps out of her
delirium. Cap finally convinces Peggy that they
can never be together… although he conveniently
leaves out the part about him dating Sharon.
When Captain America first meets Sharon
Carter, she looks so much like Peggy that
he actually thinks he's hallucinating. At the
time, Sharon is on a mission for S.H.I.E.L.D.,
trying to prevent Batroc the Leaper from
obtaining a chemical compound called Inferno
42. They later reunite while trying to
take down A.I.M. and MODOK. Soon after,
she helps Cap and Black Panther bring down Baron
Zemo after the notorious villain obtains a death
ray - and these are just a small handful of Agent
13's adventures in the Silver Age of Comics.
Sharon works frequently with Steve
Rogers during this era, but Cap never
fully embraces her as a partner: Unfortunately,
he's always too worried about her personal safety
to realize how lethal - and useful - she can be.
It doesn't help that he's also kinda obsessed
with Bucky's death at this point, and can't
stand the thought of losing another partner.
Both Captain America and Sharon Carter
flirt with retirement on multiple occasions,
always in the hope that they
might settle down together.
Cap is the first to consider this, when
they're reunited for the first time - heck,
he even makes plans to propose to her. When
he realizes he's about to be replaced by a
bunch of cosplayers, however, he realizes
that he can't hang up the shield just yet.
Nonetheless, Cap tries to get Sharon to quit on
multiple occasions. At first, she's resistant
to the idea, but she eventually agrees to take
an inactive role with S.H.I.E.L.D. that places
her firmly on the sidelines. Later, Sharon regains
her full-time role with S.H.I.E.L.D., as Nick Fury
claims her PhD in metaphysical psychology makes
her too valuable an agent to lose. Sharon is
subsequently put in charge of an all-women cadre
of S.H.I.E.L.D. agents called the Femme Force.
There is a brief time during which
Sharon decides she's had enough of
S.H.I.E.L.D. and finally quits to be
with Cap. Not long after, however,
Cap defeats the Secret Empire and learns that it's
headed by a high-ranking government official. He's
so disillusioned by this revelation that he
quits his role as Captain America, and when
Hawkeye talks Steve into becoming a new kind of
hero, Sharon is less than enthused by the idea.
"You didn't see that coming?"
Ultimately, Cap's decision to walk
the hero's path puts an end to his
dreams of living an idyllic life with Sharon.
Even by the standards of the Marvel Universe,
Doctor Faustus is a truly vile villain. His
entire modus operandi is violating people's
free will to make them his mind-slaves,
and the subtle nature of his powers make him
especially difficult to root out and destroy.
He manipulates Peggy Carter for years,
although he never learns anything of much use.
Then William Burnside, the twisted Captain
America of the 1950s, comes under his control,
compelling him to become the leader of a
neo-Nazi group called the National Force.
At this point, Cap and Sharon have been
on-again, off-again for a long time.
She's still mad at him for choosing life as
Captain America over her, and is busy flirting
with her neighbor, the pacifist Dave Cox. Sharon
soon returns to active duty, and ends up acting
as a S.H.I.E.L.D. liaison for the New York police
during their investigation of the National Force.
When she goes undercover, however, she
quickly comes under the influence of Faustus,
who makes her one of his foot soldiers.
During a battle against the National Force,
Cap loses sight of Sharon, who is later
revealed to have self-immolated alongside a
number of other National Force agents. For all
intents and purposes, Sharon Carter is dead.
Except, of course, she isn't.
"What a twist."
It's eventually revealed that Sharon has
actually been sent on a deep cover mission
in Europe - but something went wrong
along the way. She got completely cut
off from S.H.I.E.L.D. and ended up
behind enemy lines, and it took her
years to make it out - with Captain America
convinced that she was dead the whole time.
Now, at this point in comics canon, the
super-soldier serum has begun to take a
toll on Cap's body. Just as he's about to die,
Sharon and her team whisk away his body and give
him a total blood transfusion from the only other
person with the serum running through their veins:
the Red Skull. As it turns out, the Red Skull
- who has been inhabiting a clone of Cap's
body for years - arranged the rescue because he
needs the real Cap to retrieve the Cosmic Cube.
The Cube is being held by a group of
fanatics from A.I.M. called the Kubekult,
a group Sharon has successfully infiltrated.
She puts the Cube in Cap's hands, knowing he'll
use its power for good, but Cap gets trapped
inside it - with Adolf Hitler, of all people.
Of course, he soon triumphs, escapes, and
defeats the Red Skull. Cap and Sharon are
reunited, and their on-again, off-again
relationship is finally turned back on.
After the "Civil War'' conflict between
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark turns deadly,
Captain America decides to end the bloodshed
by turning himself in. On his way to his trial,
however, he's gunned down by a mysterious sniper.
Shortly after the news of Cap's death goes public,
Sinthia "Sin" Schmidt, daughter of the Red Skull,
corners a frantic Sharon in a hospital bathroom.
She then tells Sharon that Doctor Faustus
has a message for her: "Remember."
Sharon realizes, to her horror, that she has
killed Captain America. It turns out that this
whole mess has been part of an elaborate
brainwashing scheme perpetrated by the Red
Skull and Doctor Faustus, who installed
a subconscious trigger in Sharon's mind
and used her to seemingly kill Cap. Thankfully, it
turns out that Cap was merely displaced in time,
After Captain America returns from his
time-travel-pseudo-death, he and Sharon
become closer than ever. Subsequently, she
joins his Secret Avengers black ops team,
and alongside a number of other heroes,
they chase the Serpent Crown to Mars,
battle the Shadow Council, and uncover the
Thule Society, a secret order of Nazis.
Then, when Peggy Carter finally dies of
old age, Sharon, Cap, and their allies come
together to mourn her passing. At the funeral,
however, a sniper starts shooting at them,
and they quickly learn that the assailant
is the World War II hero Codename: Bravo.
Bravo was lost on an extradimensional mission,
eventually returning and aligning himself with
a new version of HYDRA. Cap is subsequently
trapped in the extradimensional Land of Nowhere,
but Sharon, alongside Fury and the
Falcon, steps up to rescue him.
One of the weirdest Cap stories ever
begins when a mysterious subway car
arrives at an abandoned station in New York.
Cap climbs on board but Sharon doesn't,
as it only has room for one. Thus, Cap is
whisked away to the brutal Dimension Z,
an alien reality that has been conquered
by Cap's old enemy, Arnim Zola. Zola seeks
to remove the super-soldier serum from
Cap, in order to give it to his children.
Cap spends the next dozen years trying to
survive, even raising Zola's son Ian as his own.
He creates an alliance with a local tribe
of monsters opposed to Zola and eventually
leads a rebellion against the villain.
Sharon manages to track him down too,
as only 30 minutes have passed on Earth.
Though Zola's daughter Jet Black switches
sides to join the heroes, Sharon is forced to
sacrifice herself to save Cap and the Earth.
Predictably, however, Sharon isn't actually dead.
Having arrived in Dimension Z, Sharon takes over
Cap's role and raises Ian as her own. When she is
finally rescued from Dimension Z by the Falcon,
she and Steve reunite. For a while, they
find peace and happiness together as they
coordinate the Avengers, but generally
refrain from going on field missions.
Sharon has acted as director of S.H.I.E.L.D. on a
couple of different occasions. The first of these
happens after she embarks on an expedition
into the Savage Land with Captain America.
As their mission comes to an end, a tender moment
between the two lovebirds is crashed by Nick Fury,
who later reveals that he's decided
to appoint Sharon as his replacement.
Years later, when Cap is replaced by the Cosmic
Cube-generated HYDRA Cap, it's revealed that the
Red Skull was behind S.H.I.E.L.D.'s initiative
to use a partial Cosmic Cube to create the
super-villain town of Pleasant Hill. The Red Skull
knew that the experiment was doomed to failure,
however, and even allowed Baron Zemo to come in
and wreck it for good measure. This was former
S.H.I.E.L.D. director Maria Hill's project, and
as such, she takes the fall for it. Evil Cap then
pushes to have Sharon take the role of director.
Instead, Sharon recommends him for the job,
with a proviso that gives him absolute power
in case of emergency. It, uh, doesn't end well.
"Hail Hydra"
The "Secret Empire" event sees Sharon step down
as S.H.I.E.L.D. director because she thinks Steve
Rogers is the right man for the job. Unfortunately
for her and everyone else, a young, sentient
Cosmic Cube named Kobik has been brainwashed by
the Red Skull, rewriting reality such that Steve
Rogers has always been a deep-cover HYDRA agent.
Steve secretly organizes an alien attack on New
York, creating a state of emergency during which
he is awarded total control of all armed forces.
Evil Cap is still in love with Sharon, however,
and gives her special treatment in his new regime.
He tries wining and dining her, then takes her
out to a "HYDRA Youth" science fair where they
see kids work on surveillance equipment
for hunting down Inhumans. When Evil Cap
survives an assassination attempt by Black
Widow and starts to doubt himself, he turns
to Sharon for reassurance. Instead, she almost
stabs him in the throat with a wooden stake.
Feeling a little peeved by this turn of events,
Cap puts Sharon in prison and has Doctor Faustus
brainwash her. Unbeknownst to Faustus, however,
Sharon has studied his voice and techniques
and is now immune to them. She poisons him,
knocks him out, and uses Cap's passwords
to bring down his strike fleet - helping to
bring an end to HYDRA's reign and ushering
in the return of the real Captain America.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.